ces médaillons jeu voilà voilà voilà
mais voilà une maman de plus qui craque
pour la youkai watch tête d'affiche des
listes de noël 2016 cette montre n'a pas
vraiment vocation à donner l'heure mais
coûteux quand même 25 euros heureusement
quand il faut faire plaisir le père noël
ne compte pas sans aucun doute sous le
sapin vous allez avoir
youkai watch donc c'est une montre dans
laquelle vous allez pouvoir glisser des
petits médaillons et l'enfant va pouvoir
jouer avec
au rayon des tout-petits compter un
budget plus important pour cette boîte
popa trouille les chiens aux allures de
policiers qui devrait faire fureur
auprès des 2 5 ans 59 euros 99
ils sont fort paisible autres jouets
phare cette année les faux animaux de
compagnie profitez-en ses peluches
animées pourrait bien vous permettre de
gagner du temps avant de devoir acheter
un véritable compagnon à quatre pattes
suffit de ne pas de passer devant il
veut bouger pouvons bouger si vous le
secouer un peu il va se mettre
il va se mettre à réagir et puis s'il
est content à ronronner
enfin si aucune de ces propositions ne
vous inspire
rassurez vous les grands classiques
feront toujours la faire faute père noël
venu chercher une robe de princesse pop
et écrits qui va avoir 3 ans et
je voudrais le costume de réponse on a
aussi une grosse tendance cette année
avec les vingt ans l'anniversaire des
pokémon avec les jeux pokémon go et puis
les jeux de cartes en sortant pensé à
faire emballer les cadeaux auprès des
associations
un geste gain de temps qui servira aussi
une bonne cause conseils du père noël